um but all right we'll get into it
like i said this is chess openings
explained i'm the host nick risco
and tonight's opening is going to be the
elephant
gambit so this is a gambit that i faced
in the tournament
just a couple months ago against the us
women's blind
champion um jessica louser
and it inspired me to study this opening
further because i really didn't know
what i was doing and found out that uh
there's some really interesting lines in
here so we'll go over it starts out with
e4 and e5 and just the king's pawn
opening
and here white goes knight to f3 and
this is just developing the knight
towards the center to attack the pawn
and the gambit now uh comes here after
pawn to d5 which
um looks a little strange at first not
going to lie
where um black is really offering up
either of these
pawns white can capture either one
and well i guess we should start looking
at what happens if we take the one on e5
with
our knight we'll get a look at pawn
takes in a little bit but i want to
cover
pretty much all the lines in this
opening we'll do a bit of a survey here
starting with knight takes e5
and after knight takes e5 there's a
couple
different moves they have here but it
looks like
the main ones are bishop to d6
and pawn takes e4 so we will start with
bishop
to d6 this is the main line here and see
what white should play now d4 is
uh the main move here just defending the
knight
it doesn't really make sense to move
backwards after we've already moved
the knight into the center we only want
to move it back later
if we really need to but we go d4 we can
defend
and now black will normally take on e4
here and now white has a couple
different options of how they can
continue
they can start with uh either bishop to
c4 they also have knight
to c4 and there is also knight
to c3 so we'll start with knight to c3
here
the material on the board is equal but
black's pawn on e4
is definitely going to become a problem
later on because
this pawn is uh already crossed to the
center it's in white's territory it's
not
the same story for white's pawn on d4 so
because of this white has a small but
lasting advantage if black doesn't do
anything about it
and white just needs to be careful not
to take on e4 too early
because if black uh develops quickly
they can generate some play on the e
file with moves like queen to e7 and
after the castle
rook to e8 and then get some play on the
e file
uh but that's about as much as i'm going
to talk about the knight c3 line here
what's a little bit more um actually
what's more interesting is bishop c4 but
i do need to cover knight c4 first here
is knight c4 this is just a very um very
safe move for white where
you retreat the knight you can't go back
to f3 or d3 so you go to c4 while you
can
and it attacks this bishop and normally
uh black is going to give up this bishop
because if you move this bishop too many
times you are going to fall behind in
development so
this is normally a safe positional
continuation where white gets the bishop
pair
but that's about it it's really hard to
to put pressure on everything else just
because both sides don't have a whole
lot developed here
in the chat njfan 9000 is asking is the
elephant gambit good for 1100 rated
players
i think that it's possible to play at um
almost any level as long as you know
what you're doing is black
there are a couple lines that do stand
up in correspondence chess
that i was looking at so i think it's
good
especially in blitz and bullets where
opponents may not be expecting it
but again you have to know your lines
pretty well because it's very easy for
black to go wrong
we'll see some of those later um
so we're gonna look at bishop c4 right
now
uh so this is after um we take on e5
they take on e4
uh and we play bishop c4 here
and really this move is just a direct
attack on f7 that forces black to give
up the bishop there's really no other
way to defend this pawn
if you try something like knight h6 i
can just capture
and then um after you take back then i
can take on f7 with either the knight or
the bishop
so you can't really defend it uh really
anyway
so you have to take on e5
and after you take on e5 it might become
uh very instinctual
to take with your d-pawn on e5 here but
there is a slight drawback here
where black can take on d1 and white
forfeits their right to castle and now
after knight c6
black uh easily at least has equality
because this pawn on e5 is a weakness
and it's very difficult to try and hold
on to it bishop f4 is your only move to
really try
but now i mean black can just continue
developing normally and then followed up
by knight g6 can be very
dangerous for whites as far as material
is concerned
so instead of taking with your d-pawn
you do have this
kind of in-between move queen to h5 and
what this does is it forks a mating
square and
the bishop so now black has to
save save himself from mate here and now
when you take with the queen and the
queens get traded off the board
the difference is that white has not
given up the right to castle which means
you can castle on the next turn bring
your rook to e1
and this pawn on e4 is going to be um
falling so that's that's the difference
between
taking right away and playing queen h5
first so a nice little
trick to know there
so that is um kind of the different
lines after
bishop to d6 i also want to take a look
at what happens if black takes back
right away on e4 once they take on e4
they're restoring material right away
both sides have
traded off a pawn now again this pawn on
e4
very weak not much that is protecting it
and that's kind of why this is still a
gambit you're pretty much going to give
up
this pawn okay so how does white
continue from here you have a knight on
e5
you have a couple open lines for your
pieces but what is the best way
to develop here well i think the
strongest way is to start with bishop to
c4
so you're getting ready to castle king
side where you can put your rook on e1
and challenge the pawn and you're also
getting this attack
on f7 uh
pablo in the chat is saying best way for
white to play is e takes d5
uh yes i'm not saying that knight takes
e5
is the best move here i'm going over a
survey of the entire opening
so uh i always get this people try and
suggest the best moves after i already
say the current line isn't good enough
just
uh make sure to be patient guys uh
always talking about the current
position so after bishop to c4 you are
hitting f7
getting ready to take with either piece
what does black do here well
black has this move queen to g5
and uh this f7 pawn is hanging
temporarily but i do want to take just a
moment here
to take a look at what exactly is going
on
right now black is saving themself from
this night fork and in addition
they are giving this threat on g2
now this position is not not equal not
winning for black this is much better
for white but
if white doesn't know what they're doing
they can go wrong very quickly for
instance
if white tries knight f7 right away
forking the queen and rook this is just
dead lost
queen takes g2 rook f1 is the only move
to save this rook and from
attack on your king and now after bishop
to g4 they're attacking the queen the
only move to save the queen is bishop e2
they uh trade on e2 and after the trade
on e2
they take the knight on f7 and here you
can see
that white is down a piece they are down
at night
um so here this is really not good
for white uh yes the king is exposed but
with one last piece is very hard
to attack you don't have a direct attack
anyway and it's hard to get this queen
out of your position right away so black
is actually going to have very easy
development bringing their pieces into
the fight
white is still going to do a little bit
of work to get this bishop out
and just being down a piece it's not
going to be a fun time
so while queen g5
does have this little trap to it there
are still two good ways
for white to continue we'll start with
looking at d4
which is a good move here and after
queen g2
now you can take on f7 with the bishop
as an in-between move you
let this rook hang for for one move
because this comes with check
and after they save the king now you go
rook f1 saving the rook
and now after knight to c6 uh any time
that this knight comes to c6 and
challenges your knight on e5
you need to make sure that you're not
going to hang this bishop on f7
so you bring this bishop back to c4
uh hey they're remembering truth um
so let's see here after bishop to c4
knight f6 and white just has a better
position here
um black's king is kind of moved they're
going to be struggling to develop their
dark square bishop and this queen
it is a little dangerous being this far
into white's position but
currently not really doing much so moves
like knight c3 aren't
terrible here bishop e3 or even bishop
um
actually not bishop g5 because the queen
so you do have to be careful
but um with normal development i think
this should be fine for white
however like i said this is not the
absolute best
try i think the best try here
is going with the bishop right away
you're going to play d4 later
just go take this pawn right away here
trying to understand what pablo is
saying in the chat here
but it looks like they're giving
notation uh
with some other languages letters and i
don't understand i'm sorry
um james barry is saying that black pawn
could be dangerous this pawn on e4
actually is not
too dangerous here most of the time it
does fall
but okay we're going to get back to this
line here after bishop takes f7
uh the king does normally go to e7
king to d8 has not been explored and
because it's never been played before
uh i'm just not gonna go over it play is
gonna remain relatively the same
if they go king d8 you just play d4 but
here after king e7
pawn to d4 here and now after queen to
g2 you go rook f1
and here there's uh kind of two
different moves that
theory suggests theory has always
suggested
knight to d7 and after knight to d7
uh again when this knight comes to
attack the knight on e5 you need to make
sure this bishop is still going to be
safe because after this trade is going
to fall
so you see bishop to c4 and white should
obtain
an advantage here with accurate play
according to theory
there is a bit of a newer idea that has
been played a couple times
with knight to c6 and
here uh it looks like if you take black
should be afraid of having doubled pawns
here
but they're actually not afraid of
having doubled pawns and not really
afraid of
the the bishops not moving here and it's
been
a bit of a debate of whether knight d7
or knight c6 is better here
and again here because the knight is
being attacked just bishop c4 and
engines will just say white is better i
do want to
just take a look here and see what is
happening if we take on c6 here with the
knight
because this is what black is kind of uh
inviting whenever he goes knight c6 but
after
the pawn takes on c6 and bishop to c4
after knight of six we realized that
without more pieces on the board white
has kind of lost that presence and black
is able to develop with ease
there's really nothing here that black
needs to be afraid of with only the
bishop developed
so like this queen is still kind of
watching the king side here this knight
may try and jump in
or the bishop so this uh is at least
equal here
i don't think black is uh so much better
but i would prefer to have black in this
position just because white has given up
that presence
in the center here so that that's kind
of what black is aiming
for if white goes for this
um and that covers pretty much
i think all of the main lines after
the knight takes on e5
so uh after knight takes e5 here in the
center
um they can take here
uh and i guess we also looked at bishop
to
d6 just d4 and if they take you can
develop attacking f7
and you just have to remember this
intermezzo with queen h5
so that's all the knight takes e5 uh
lines
now you notice here black does have
moves that give them a couple traps a
couple advantages there
stuff that white does have to watch out
for so with white we also want to take a
look at what happens if you take on d5
and this one i will recommend e takes d5
i have to say is better than taking with
the knight
so e takes d5 there's a couple things
happening here
it looks like you're just trading off
pawns but we'll get into what happens if
the queen takes we'll get into what
happens if the pawn pushes
and i think we will start right away
just by looking at what happens if the
queen takes
this variation in the elephant gambit is
known as the scandinavian variation
and for those of you who are unfamiliar
the scandinavian
as e4 d5 takes and then
the queen takes is what the old main
lines were
nowadays knight f6 is more popular but
most
uh openings where there's a capture on
d5 and the queen recaptures
has the name scandinavian variation in
it
because of this opening so after the
queen takes here we enter the
scandinavian variation of the elephant
gambit
now this is not recommended mainly
because this is a worse
version of the scandinavian for black
normally in a regular scandinavian
black is going to be able to play pawn
to c6 and e6
and then bring the queen to a5 and bring
it back on the diagonal
but here in most lines this uh
this queen is just gonna be out in the
open and white
really is able to take advantage of this
to develop
um energetically so knight to c3
attacking the queen
queen goes to e6 and now after bishop to
b5
check black does get c6 like they want
and after bishop a4
just saving the bishop one of black's
better moves here
is queen to g6 just making sure that
they can bring their bishop into the
game either on f5
or g4 and kind of just keep the center
open for the rest of their pieces here
um after queen to g6 queen to e2
is the main move hitting e5
and now there's um
a little problem here if black tries and
takes on g2
so you might be worried that black is
going to take here but in this line they
actually
don't have the time to take white has a
series of moves to get this
rook into the game a little
unconventionally
so after rook to g1 and queen to h3 the
only move to save the queen
there's rook g3 forcing the queen to h5
and it's important you force this queen
to go to h5 because now at the rook
g5 you're forking forking the queen and
the pawn here so after queen h3 you take
on e5 with the rook
and i don't think it takes a grand
master to realize this position
is worse for black so
because of this little maneuver with the
rook queen takes g2
is losing so black should play something
more like
bishop to e6 and then after castles
knight d7 and d4 white is doing just
fine
all of their pieces are going to get out
in the game the rooks are going to come
to the center
black does get to castle queen side but
they're lacking in development on the
king side here
and i feel like black just really isn't
going to to catch up
so this is the scandinavian variation
just so people know
that does exist and what is going on but
like i said
queen takes d5 i i do not recommend as
the best move most scandinavian
variations of
other openings are just sub-par
variations of the normal scandinavian
and if you want to play the scandinavian
you should just play
play it right away you shouldn't be
trying to go into some weird sideline
here
which is a variation of it because
they're generally worse
okay so if you are not going to go
queen takes d5 what else are you going
to play so i want to make sure black
doesn't have any other moves
here but um checking my notes real quick
looks like there are two moves left
one is bishop to d6 and the other
is pawn to e4
so we're going to look at bishop to d6
first
this is known as the moroxi variation
named after the hungarian grand master
who often played this line as black and
really all they're doing is developing
the bishop and protecting the pawn
now some people may think this is a
little bit of a waste of time because
this bishop is kind of blocking the
center just to defend a piece maybe
you'd rather push
but there are some pluses to this um
first you are
protecting your hanging pawn and then
also this bishop is going to be
attacking white's position
after the push so there are some pluses
here
now we're going to get into what white
plays here
white can play pawn to d4 here
and this is the most played uh move
and really the best there's a couple
other moves there's
bishop to b5 which is one
and then is there a third yes the third
is like knight c3 but we'll get into
that in just a second we'll start off
with pawn to d4 the most played and uh
practically best try here for white
so after d4 black normally plays e4
gets this push in again opens up the
bishop hits the knights
and now the knight just goes to e5 it
might seem a little strange allowing
black to just take
but first off this opening really uh for
black they want to keep their bishops
because losing these pawns in the center
will open up the lines for them
and then also here uh if you take
and white takes back these pawns are
going to be very strong just kind of
cramping black's position here
and this pawn on e4 you should just
forget about it white's gonna win that
easily
so 95 and here there's the move
knight to f6 now after knight to f6
there's a couple different ideas here
the main one for white is just to go
bishop b5 check
and now black can block the check with
either the bishop or the knight
if they block with the bishop we can
take with our knight on e5
and we win the bishop pair and then now
both sides castle
we get c4 just building up our center
protecting d5 from the knight and after
a6 hitting the bishop we can just trade
this off
and after knight to c3 i think white has
a very nice plus here
very big pawn center a lot space rook is
ready to go to e1
e4 is still a target this
should be just fine if black tries to
block with the knight
this can lead to some complications
mainly
because of this move here bishop to g5
bishop to g5 i think is much more potent
than what people will give it credit for
what this is doing is threatening to
take on f6
and double the pawns now how are you
going to do that if we take on f6 right
away the queen can take back well
you have to time this correctly so first
white sorry black castles
and now you can take on d7
with the bishop and force these trades
where now after the queen has gone on d7
it has
forgotten this knight on f6 and now you
can make this capture
and while this position isn't absolutely
garbage
for black this one does present some
problems
with openings on the king side so black
may try to remedy this with king to h8
and rook to g8
getting some pressure on the king side
now that this isn't the best choice of
moves for either side but this is just
an illustrative example of how this can
go
kind of how white wants now because of
these ideas of bishop to g5
the other move in this position rather
than knight f6
was suggested by ej diemer the same guy
who helped develop the black mardemer
gambit
and he recommends knight to e7 and this
is to
avoid this pin where the the pawn has to
recapture
and it just reduces the possibilities of
erect king side
the problem with this is that this move
is rather passive
and uh it will give white some chances
to get an advantage here because what's
happening is the knight
um isn't really influencing the center
as much as it could be it's blocking the
development of
the other pieces but this does avoid the
pin
so um some people would say that
the avoiding avoiding the problems on
the king side is worth it but i think um
general consensus is this move is just a
little too passive
but i do want to show that that one does
exist
and then now the last move i guess i
already covered
bishop e5 is just white takes back and
this should just be better for white
okay uh let's see checking on the
youtube chat here
uh james barry usually dislikes losing
the bishops
yes that is kind of the idea for black
carry you don't want to give up the
bishop pair
with these pawns gone the bishops do get
a lot of space
a lot of open lines
okay so we had pawn to d4 here
and we talked about all the responses
that black hat
uh let's talk about bishop to b5
this is another move that white has at
their disposal
and blackface is an uncomfortable choice
here so like i said d4 is most played
probably the
best line for white but bishop to b5 can
be a little surprising like i said
black has to make an uncomfortable
decision here what do they do
to to get rid of this check now king f8
you really don't want to give up your
right to castle here
you want to make sure you can develop
very actively
so the choices you have are to sacrifice
a pawn with c6
uh or you go bishop d7 and lose the
bishop pair
or excuse me you go knight to d7
and you block your bishop from
developing and it's really
i mean black really has to weigh what
they're getting in each of these lines
so we'll start with c6 after c6 black's
queen side pawns will not be the
greatest because you are giving up a
pawn over here
and because you're already down upon
from the
initial elephant gambit that's just
probably going to weigh much more than
the potential activity
black is going to get from this so white
should take on d6 and now black does
need to take back
knight takes c6 is the most played move
and a bit better
but we'll take a look at what happens if
the pawn takes if the pawn takes you
just save your bishop
put some pressure on this f7 square
knack knight to f6
knight c3 you're developing normally
bishop to g4
d3 to open up your own bishop castle's
castles white has
a little bit of a plus here because of
the development
this knight um probably gonna have to go
to d7
uh because it can't go to c6 so the
knight is just going to be a little bit
more active for white
and this bishop is going to be able to
develop easily
we'll go back to knight captures pawn d3
really just opening up the line for the
bishop knight to e7
kind of connecting the knights here and
now a little bit of a strange
move you're probably going to be
expecting something like castles or
knight c3
uh which are still completely fine here
but i was doing some work
with um it was stockfish 13 here
and pawn to a4 is the uh
looks to be the best move here and what
this is doing is after something like
pawn to a6
or really after castles where this pin
is no longer
important the bishop wants to drop back
and this avoids any kind of a6 b5 in the
future where the bishop has to go back
or even just knight a5 in this position
now you can drop the bishop all the way
back to a2
and now white doesn't need to worry
about giving up their bishop
pair so black will play something like
h6 here trying to stop the pieces from
coming in
and i think white also has a nice little
advantage
here so
that's if they play pawn to c6 the other
options
bishop to d7 here after bishop to d7
you just make the trade and the knight
comes to d7
you can castle they play knight to f6
and now knight c3
all this development should be pretty
natural
you see black castle rook to e1 hitting
e5 rook goes to e8 to kind of support it
and after pawn to d4 and e4 you play
knight to e2
and this pawn on e4 is a little loose
so uh snowflake thank you for joining us
for your first
time nice to have you here um
so i don't knight d2 white is a little
better here uh the queen is looking to
probably come to e2 but it's uh
you don't want to rush it but e4 is the
target here
now the other move they have is knight
d7
and this move also makes more sense um
or not more sense that also makes sense
because
uh you're not giving up this light
squared bishop which is an
important attacking piece for black like
i said black really wants to keep their
bishops
so you don't get that traded off right
away the other plus is that you're not
giving up another pawn on the queen side
so you're retaining a little bit of
integrity over on that side of the board
and you also retain the possibility of
winning back this d5 pawn
uh very slim chances but they're still
there
so this move might be my recommendation
if black were to go into this line
uh now after knight to c3 get knight to
f6
again you see this normal development
now here in this line after e4 this
knight goes to g5
hitting the pawn right away from up
front
and now after castles castles you'll
notice this line is very similar
to the bishop d7 line but the difference
is that one the knight is
a bit more aggressively posted two the
rooks are not
on the e-file so you don't have this
extra activity happening
on the e-file and then the light squared
bishops are still
on the board so still more chances for
both sides
so this move probably going to be the
best continuation for black that they
find
themselves in this situation
and that kind of covers all of the
bishop b5 check
um okay so now after bishop to d6 in the
moroccy variation
we do want to take a look at um knight
to c3
because this might be a beginner's
natural instinct
develop the knights before the bishops
now
this move is not horrible by any means
you are developing a piece
definitely good but just because it's
not bad doesn't mean it's great
um in all the other lines white is
definitely making an active push to try
and
attack on this e-file maybe win the
e-pawn um
so after knight c3 there's really no
obvious opening advantage here
besides you still have the d5 pawn
currently on the board
and you're upon up so other moves in
this position like knight c3 which are
fine is like
pawn to c4 is one queen to e2
is one d3 is one and bishop c4
all these are are not horrible moves but
they're not great moves
so um black or sorry white
can avoid some of those uh and i think
that covers
all of the meroxy variation here um so
like i said i think
d4 is going to be the best push here
because black really doesn't get a very
easy way to develop on the king
side later on okay let me just scroll
down
check my notes one more time make sure
that was everything
looks like it was which means now we can
move on to
kind of the last variation here in the
elephant gambit
that black can go for and probably the
most active one that
i really just appreciate that it exists
is pawn to e4 and uh
we have uh jane in this asking what is
meroxy
that is the name of this bishop d6
variation that was named after
a hungarian grand master uh meraki
uh he's also uh has the meroxy bind and
the sicilian that's a bit more
more well known
but okay we're gonna be looking at the
advanced variation now
now advanced variation doesn't mean that
this is for advanced players
only advanced variation is just saying
this pawn is advancing
one more square forward
so this is a very sharp possibility
where black is looking to fight right
away
just because it is attacking the knight
here and white obviously has to do
something about this
now rather than just move the knight
where black can retake on d5 with the
queen
or develop with bishop to c5 other
active moves
we actually go queen to e2 and
this move is a bit of an x clam here
because you don't move the knight it
looks like this knight is still in
trouble
but with this move white is really
putting the pressure on e4 and really
asking black what what are you doing
about this pawn here
so after queen to e2 black does need to
worry about this pawn a little bit
and they normally defend with knight 2f6
now uh there are two moves here for
white
um there's d3 which we'll get into in
just a second and there's knight
c3 now i want to cover knight c3 first
because after um d3 there are some
differences we need to worry about
um so here knight c3 it makes a lot of
sense because you're trying to win this
pawn and you are attacking with the
knight
but there are some tactics that exist
for black or some tactical opportunities
um where really one of the main ones is
that
white is going to struggle to get these
pieces off of the e
file which means that after black
castles kingside they can put a rook on
e8
and then try and win the queen
so we'll look into this a little bit
more
bishop to e7 sorry i should con uh
explain
why this is happening um here so there
are a few moves
uh that black has i guess i'm confusing
my lines a little bit here
but bishop e7 is the most played and
after knight takes e4
knight d5 just win the pawn back no need
to trade the knights and stay down upon
uh my recommendation here is that the
queen just goes back to d1
this is not the most popular not the
most popular move here but i think it's
just the
the simplest for whites so after castles
bishop to c4 hitting the knight
um knight to c6 and then rather than
taking you don't want to give up your
bishop pair you just castle and this
kind of just
solves most of the problems white can
face
from black here just because you finally
have those pieces off the e file
you do give up a little bit of time here
though because you do have to take that
extra tempo to bring the queen back
but i think giving that tempo is worth
it in order to avoid
uh any problems from rook to e8 in the
future
so bishop to g4 is the main move here
and you can play h3 just to kick the
bishop
and here black's best move is to take
the reason why it's to take normally
you'll go bishop to g5 but with this
knight on e4
an idea that some players might be
familiar with from the rui lopez or
the italian is knight to g3 and it hits
this bishop again
and if it goes back to g6 rook to e1
and white is very rapidly catching up in
this development
now they just need to play d3 and
they're pretty much good to go this
bishop is ready to hop into the action
um or even just c3 and d4 and wait to
develop this bishop at a later date
so after bishop takes f3 queen takes f3
now we see knight to d4
hitting the queen and the c2 pawn just
queen to d1
yet again but now black has no problems
and white is up a healthy pawn
and that is going to be where white gets
their play is in this end game they have
the bishop pair
and an extra center pawn that's going to
be what they're playing on
so that is knight c3 now even though
this
is playable there is a better move
is pawn to d3 and
theoretically this position um
after d3 can almost be viewed as a
refutation
however as one of our favorite grand
masters have said
theory and practice are the same in
theory but not in practice
if you look this position up in a
database um
it's not a clean win for white
every single time this position is
actually around 50
win for white and 30 draw
with 23 uh win for black
which is still good chances for black um
if they are playing this position
so let's get into some of the theory
here see why this move can be so strong
well right away you are attacking this
pawn again
which is what we're trying to do we're
trying to attack this pawn win the pawn
on e4
and black is trying to castle develop
and get ready
and now we reach another one of those
weird decisions
here we're going to look at the problems
of developing the bishop and what move
black should play instead
so if black is trying to castle right
away
there's a couple moves they can look at
first is
bishop to e7 now this one doesn't take
much calculation to realize why this
move
might be poor is that even if they
castle and get the rook to e8
they've now blocked the e-file for
themselves which is where black is going
to be getting that
compensation for the pawn so
you're just blocking yourself you're not
going to get that compensation you want
so after pawn takes and castles
knight c3 rookie 8 bishop to e3
just blocks off this file from any
tactics and now after bishop to b4
knight to d2 and the reason knight to d2
is played is because e4 is attacked
and after bishop takes you want there to
at least be um
something here so that way after these
trades you're not completely toast
something like queen d3 is going to be
fine here white is still going to have a
very healthy game
so bishop e7 not a great move for black
bishop c5 is an improvement but
here white is still going to be better
pawn takes e4
castles knight c3 rookie 8 these
standard moves that we just saw
and now instead of bishop to e3 we get
bishop to g5
the idea is you are pinning this knight
so you are removing an attacker from the
e4 pawn
we see pawn to h6 with the idea that if
you go back
i'm going to play g5 and after the
bishop moves back again i'm going to
capture on e4
actually you probably can't do that
right away because of the knight but
that's that's the
general idea here so bishop takes on f6
just removing this attacker
queen takes on f6 and now white gets to
roll these pawns down the board you go
e5
queen goes to f5 and now castles queen
side
you get the king off of the e file so
you don't have to worry about any rookie
5 nonsense
knight to d7 again helping for rook
to e5 and now white has a
an interesting maneuver here that is not
very well known it's been played in one
game before and i think it was in a
computer championship here
where white goes knight to b5 hitting
the c pawn
threatening to fork so bishop to b6
to protect and we get a very interesting
move that is
uh very reminiscent of alpha zero
is pawn to e6 and you
give up this pawn now why are you giving
up this pawn why do you sacrifice it
well you're going to lose this pawn
anyway there's just too many attackers
on it for you to defend again
and rather than just make some move um
right away if you push it right now the
only way for them to take
is with their pawn and
here now that this f pawn has left the
pawn island on the king side
this pawn is now a new target that's
going to stick around for the rest of
the game so this is going to be
a more static target this isolated
king's pawn
and now rather than taking and letting
black get some activity
you push the pawn to d6 and you're
threatening to take on c7 again
so after c6 knight c7
take take and now they get rid of this
fork problem and white has this past
pawn that's all the way up the board
okay and now after something like pawn
to e5 queen to e3
opening up the path for the bishop this
is just fine for white white is going to
be much better and white went on to win
this game
okay uh now we're going to go
look at instead of bishop to c5 we're
going to look at what happens if they go
bishop to b4 with this
check so this is another thing that's
happening here is um
black can try and get this tempo right
away and if white plays c3 they don't
even have to move the bishop
back they can castle right away because
if you take
they're going to take on f3 and now
after queen takes knight takes d5
and now suddenly it's black who is
better black is actually better in this
position
so you can't just allow them to take on
f3
so you take on e4 with the pawn
and now we see bishop c5 saving the
bishop
bishop to g5 again pinning the knight to
remove an attacker
and rook to e8 knight to d2 to defend
and pawn c6 takes on c6 takes on c6 and
castles queen side and
now white has just escaped any problems
black can pose in the opening here
they're ready to go with moves like
knight c4 e3 and d5
or knight to b3 just hitting the bishop
and the queen
so here white is also going to have a
healthy advantage
so if none of these bishop moves are
working out for black i think we have to
come to the conclusion that black should
not be trying to castle
soon here there actually is a move here
that is fine for black
and it is queen takes d5 this is again a
bit more of a newer idea um
and i i mean here uh
i mean this seems to be playable i
believe this is still being played in
correspondence
with queen to d5 and now some of the
developing ideas for whites are going to
include
knight to d2 hitting e4 again
and now after black develops knight c6
you can take on e4 with your pawn
hitting the queen now the queen moves
and pawn to h3 this is stopping any
knight to g4 or in the future bishop to
g4
and now bishop to d6 you can go queen e3
and this is opening up your bishop again
after castles bishop to d3 because after
rookie 8 there's going to be more
pressure on e4
that's why the bishop is going to d3
instead of c4
knight to d7 looking to go to c5 hitting
the bishop
and the pawn so pawn to c3 is a way
around this
this was uh one of the moves that i
didn't see right away
but this is a very interesting idea is
just play pawn to c3
now if they go knight to c5 you can just
tuck the bishop away on c2
and you still maintain your control over
e4
but now instead we'll see bishop to c5
this is a bit more common
and here um not the most played move i
think the most played move here is queen
e2
but i was asking myself why why can i
not just play knight d4 here
um and i don't believe this has been
played before but this is going to be my
recommendation is you just go knight to
d4
and there has to be some liquidation i
mean
you're attacking both both of these
pieces now they they don't have to take
uh honestly you're hoping they take so
you can recapture with the pawn
and then still have a nice nice center
here um but they don't have to instead
they can just play knight d
to e5 hitting the bishop and once the
bishop goes back to c2
uh this position is pretty equal i think
queen g6
is an idea here hitting the g pawn and
uh i was looking at it it looks like
king side
castle should be fine for white so this
is going to be my recommendation
is uh this knight d4 move um
rather than queen e2 and this position
as far as i know is still being worked
out with the theory
still being tested in games um
as far as i know there has not been a a
set
opinion on this position but i think
it's very interesting for both sides and
if black is going to play the elephant
gambit
this should be the type of position they
are looking for
but that is basically all the theory i
have prepared for you guys tonight
this is chess openings explained run
over the elephant's gambit
we have about seven minutes left here so
i do want to open it up to
any questions the chat may have so if
there's a specific position
if you can remember what line it was if
you can say the name of the line and
what move
that would be helpful that way i know
exactly what you're talking about
and we'll be able to answer any
questions you have
um so yeah with that being said uh i'm
going to turn to the chat and see
what is popping up uh
frank kepler saying whoa i should have
an engine confirming what's on the board
i did have an engine confirm i was using
stock fish 13 at depth
40 earlier um
and you're probably freaking out because
it says white is much better
but if you look at all of these lines
white is usually just plus one in
everything
and this is a position that so far has
not been worked out so if you get this
in a tournament game
i mean no one's going to have an engine
with them at a tournament
so this position should just be playable
for black here um definitely not the
best position i'm not recommending
like play the elephant gambit over like
the night or
i'd be foolish to recommend that but if
you are going to be playing the elephant
this is what i'm uh expecting black to
try and go for i think this is one of
the best
tries
okay um
what else is happening in the chat hey
nick nice to see you again
what is the next opening we're bringing
to the channel next week
i don't have anything specific planned
right now i do have a couple openings in
the works
so if there's anything you would like to
see specifically
just drop a recommendation in the chats
or in the comments
after this video gets published i always
take a look at that to see what people
want
uh james barry isn't it kind of bad to
have two files open next to each other
uh i don't know who told you that but
that that is simply incorrect there are
a lot of openings where
having the two center files open are
just completely great it's actually very
good for your rooks
your rooks get to go to the center of
the board they have full control of the
open files
so i i have to disagree having the two
files next to each other
is not bad there may be some certain
situations where it is and that might be
what you're referring to but in general
i
i cannot say that uh that would be bad
okay uh looks like we're getting a
question in the main line
with black playing pawn to e4 so the
advanced variation
what do i think about knight e5 followed
by d4
this is playable um
black can take and then if you want d4
right away this is definitely
looking like it's playable uh if they
take on d3
you just recapture with the knight but
the problem here is that
after everything's been traded off in
the center yeah you are going to get a
tempo on the queen
but what are your threats you don't have
any like
tension or anywhere to fight for which
is one of the problems with
trading your pieces very early on is
that if all you do is trade your pieces
um you could be thinking oh i'm trading
closer to a draw which if you want to
draw that's fine
but when you trade a piece you're also
reducing your chances
significantly to build up that pressure
and get that
activity to convert into an advantage
and ideally convert that advantage into
a win
so if you trade too many things uh
really early you lose a lot of your
chances and i feel like with this line
you are losing
a lot of chances
so hopefully that answers your question
amir ansari what if black plays queen g6
and then captures on d4 with the knight
or bishop
i would like you to tell me what line
that is because queen g6 has played a
lot i don't know what line exactly
you're talking about
and let's see uh queen g6 and captures
on d4
with the knight of bishops so you're
probably talking about this main line
here
uh well okay after queen g6 we castles
and now if they take
i mean i'm gonna be super happy if they
take with the knight
if they take with the knight i take with
the pawn and this is a fork
um so they would have to take with the
bishop and even if
they take with the bishop i'm still
super happy because what's happening is
i get a recapture with the pawn
and now look who has the pawn center
white has the pawn center
black does not so white's gonna have a
lot of control over this game
and black needs to be careful not to let
these pawns just run down the board
so uh i mean i'm sorry i hope that's the
position you were talking about
that is kind of the idea i had when i
came up with knight to d4
nj fan 9000 is recommending i make a
video on the two nights defense
uh i'm assuming that's for that's
against the italian right
i'm not too familiar with like uh one e5
from black uh just because i don't play
it personally
um and then
uh i may have creative insults but none
that i can share on stream
so um
frank kepler chess isn't all about
winning well i mean if you
if you try not to win in chess i mean i
don't know why you would play chess if
all you're playing for is a draw
uh i mean here i'm here to teach people
how to win
uh how to maximize their chances so for
me chess is all about winning because
it's my job to help people win
can i quickly teach the sicilian i could
but i'm not going to because
i've already released a couple videos on
the channel caleb dunby's done an
amazing series on the najdorf on our
channel
so if you want to learn the sicilian if
you want to learn a specific line we
already have
tons of content available on our youtube
channel that you can check out
after the stream ends
okay um we are wrapping up our time here
i'll give it just
another minute or two in case there's
any last minute questions
uh after this stream ends here on
youtube we are going to switch to twitch
where we are going to resume my series
the winners
circle where we are following smislov's
wins
in the 1953 candidates we took like a
three week break
because of the candidates and we also
have some construction going on at the
chess club regarding our new expansion
um but we're back we're back i'm
streaming here from home we have our
openings class back on mondays
we have the winner's circle happening
right after this on twitch
make sure to check that out
okay um oh frank was just uh justifying
the insults okay i understand
um okay with their cosmon is asking do i
know a super gm that plays or
used to play the elephant uh right off
the top of my head
i do not but it would not surprise me if
magnus has whipped it out from time to
time
uh let me pull up the position here
after d5 check the database real quick
um looks like super gm's it looks like
um mvl has played this i would doubt it
was in a classical game
um but uh mvl played this against uh
most session in 2010 and that is the
first game that's popping up here on the
leeches database
uh if we're looking at ed5 and
um i guess e4
i guess this is the line that he played
as well so he does have one game in the
database here
um he also lost that game so i don't
know what that says about it
but um definitely in blitz i would say
try this one out definitely going to
catch your opponent off guard
and like i said after knight takes e5
black still has a lot of tricks
definitely possible and most people who
see this position for the first time
will take on e5 because they're worried
about the queen taking
now after you watch this video you know
queen taking isn't that great
but i mean uh there's definitely tricks
here for both sides um
what channel what's the twitch account
yeah so after this is over
when we go to twitch it's gonna be on
stl chess club so it's still gonna be
the st
louis chess clubs um
it's not going to be my own twitch here
but i do stream test on my own twitch
from time to time chesmar remote tv if
you want to check it out
um let's see people are requesting
blackmart deemer gambit
uh why does magnus not have famous
unbelievable games like fisher or
bobby well okay bobby fischer is the
same guy
uh orange well i mean
magnus's defense i don't have any of
anon's games memorized i think fischer
was just very popular because of
the um what else was happening in the
world at that time it was a very big us
versus russia
not just in chess but in everything else
i mean we had the space race
that was the other big one um so i think
it was just that those are famous
because of the time period and they're
also famous just because um
they're older they're older
but yeah i mean all the magnus's games
are still happening now give it a
century i'm sure people will have some
of his games
um memorized
and no like creative games uh
i would encourage you to go back and
check magnus's games then because magnus
definitely has creative games if you
look at his games and say he doesn't
have creativity
uh i i don't know um
but they definitely uh definitely are
creative
okay one last question from exo get it
in the chat and then we'll uh switch
over to twitch we are starting to run
over time here
yeah james berry does have a point
magnus can play garbage openings against
other super gm's
and still win i mean the last two titled
arenas on leachat he's been playing the
bomb cloud and just absolutely crushing
so
oh the last question of the night is
would i rather play monopoly forever
or chess to never exist uh well i guess
if
i play monopoly forever i'm not playing
chess
so it's like chess never existed eh
uh i'm stuck on that question i'm gonna
i'm gonna plead the fifth on that one
and claim that uh i have nothing to do
with monopoly
uh good question though but okay
um but okay i uh
i think that is all we have for tonight
i do see some of the other comments
coming in tonight
um i mean i'm just giving quick answers
to the questions guys i mean i'm not
like a doctor in history
or or chess you know i'm just giving
quick answers to what i think makes
sense to me
it's all opinion but that is it that is
chess openings explained that is the
elephant gambit
hopefully some of you guys got inspired
by this some of you may check it out
some of you guys may know how to play
against it now if you have any cool
games with it
uh you know import it and delete us drop
the link in the comment section love to
see your guys's results with this
again any uh any recommendations for new
openings drop in the comments as well
i'm always taking a look for them
but uh yeah we're gonna wrap it up here
on youtube and move to twitch so
thank you everybody for showing up we'll
see you over there